las llamas invaden la torre de esta
iglesia y los bomberos luchan en vano
para apagar el fuego fue una de las
imágenes del final de la jornada de
protestas en santiago decenas de miles
de ciudadanos se movilizaron al
cumplirse un año del estallido social
contra la desigualdad en el país las
manifestaciones se desarrollaron de
forma pacífica hasta el final del día
cuando se desataron algunos episodios de
violencia y saqueos los carabineros
respondieron con gases lacrimógenos y
cañones de agua
las pensiones que es lo que estamos
luchando llevamos más de un año luchando
por las pensiones sueldos estudio todo
cachai pero yo por mi sector yo no veo
ningún cambio las protestas de 2019
iniciaron por un alza en la tarifa del
metro de santiago pero rápidamente se
convirtieron en un reclamo más amplio
por mejor acceso a la salud y de
educación cambios en el sistema de
pensiones y sobre todo una reforma de la
constitución de carácter neoliberal
heredada de la dictadura de augusto
pinochet la violenta respuesta policial
a esas movilizaciones dejó más de 30
muertos y miles de heridos
el llamado un referendo constitucional y
sobre todo la pandemia de kobe 19
hicieron mermar las protestas pero éstas
renovaron su fuerza a una semana del
plebiscito hasta la oportunidad de decir
basta
las unas a orinar el próximo fin de
semana y será la oportunidad para que
los manifestantes se expresen
democráticamente contra la constitución
considerada por ellos como la base de
las desigualdades en el país